it is no secret that amazon.com is
dominating multiple aspects of our daily
lives we can find just about everything
we could possibly need on their sites
and if you've got Amazon Prime you only
wait two days for free delivery for our
digital media we can read books on
Kindle listen to music on Alexa and we
can also watch on-demand movies and TV
series this all started with an idea
that exploded into a digital revolution
so who is the man behind the trillion
dollar company well on today's episode
of biographic s-- we're talking about
Jeff Bezos On January the 12th 1964 a
seventeen-year-old girl named Jacqueline
Gea's gave birth to a baby boy named
Jeffrey Preston jorgeson in Albuquerque
New Mexico she was married to Jeff's
biological father Terry Augustine for
just a one year while she was finishing
earning a high school diploma but the
relationship it was not meant to last
and they got a divorce Jacquelyn later
remarried a man named Mike Bezos who was
a Cuban immigrants who earned a college
scholarship in the u.s. they had two
children together and they also gave
Jeff the last name Bezos Jeff grew up in
a very loving and supportive family his
stepfather Mike was very resourceful and
hard-working yes mother was very loving
and supportive and she was especially
concerned about making sure that her son
got the best education possible
she put Jeff into a Montessori School
the idea behind this educational method
is to allow a child to excel in their
natural talents so they choose what they
want to learn at their own pace instead
of forcing every child to learn the same
things at the same time
Jeff was extremely focused on his
schoolwork even from a young age after
the allotted time in each subject was up
his teachers had a hard time getting him
to move on to the next topic in
preschool they had to pick him up while
still sitting in his chair and move him
just to break his concentration Jeff
Bezos spent his summer vacations living
with his grandparents and helping them
run their ranch in Texas his
grandparents owned an Airstream trailer
so they would go on long road trips
vacations together as well during these
road trips he would
find excuses to do math problems on a
scrap of paper like their average gas
mileage and how much they were spending
on groceries even though he helps around
the ranch with the chores he did not
particularly enjoy the outdoors and he
preferred to watch TV and read books at
a very early age Jeff Bezos was showing
signs that he was a genius
his grandfather was also a very
intelligent man and he could see the
potential in Jeff's future so his
grandfather gave him some very valuable
advice which stuck with him for the rest
of his life Bezos explained it's harder
to be kind than clever cleverness is a
gift kindness is a choice and choices
can be hard you can seduce yourself with
your gifts if you're not careful he
spent the rest of his life reminding
himself that no matter how much he
accomplished he would try to stay
down-to-earth at home his mother allowed
him to have a workshop in their garage
where he built a solar cooker a
hovercraft and even installed a security
alarm on his bedroom door he was
competing in science fairs reading
science fiction and watching episodes of
Star Trek on TV when he was just 10
years old he found a teletype computer
at his school he and his friends found
out that there was a Star Trek game
pre-programmed into the system called
track 73 so he and his friends used the
computer to play this game this sparked
his interest in computer programming and
it would carry on for the rest of his
life Jeff Bezos started his first
business in high school he was
disappointed by the quality of his towns
local summer camp where kids were just
playing games outside most of the day
and not really learning anything so he
founded a new camp called the dream
Institute they allowed kids from the
fourth fifth and sixth grade to attends
and focused on teaching children about
important works of literature in a fun
exciting way the business it was a
success and many of these kids who were
doing their summer reading would go on
to get better grades in school not
surprisingly he was the valedictorian of
his high school class and during his
graduation speech he said that he
believed that one day human beings would
colonize space after graduation he
attended Princeton University and earned
a degree in computer science his first
job was at a startup called fit all
while he worked there he was expected to
fly between New York and London nearly
every week in order to get his job done
which was costing the company
Mendes amount of money he realized that
this was not the most efficient way to
run a business and it got into thinking
about all the different things that he
would do more efficiently if he got to
run his own company in the future his
next job was at Bankers Trust which gave
him some experience in the financial
industry next he worked for an
investment firm on Wall Street called
de Shore he helped to develop software
for trading stocks online as the years
went on Jeff Bezos was staying on top of
the news about the growth of the
Internet
he realized that every single year the
number of people who were using the
Internet was increasing by 2300 percent
even though the world wide web had many
naysayers he knew that the Internet
wasn't just a passing fad and it would
become a part of people's daily lives
very soon
he knew early on to take advantage of
this and Bezos figured that if he could
genuinely create an online business that
would help make people's lives easier it
would last his motto was think about the
customer and then work from there
[Music]
before Jeff Bezos met his wife Mackenzie
he said that he was always looking for a
resourceful woman because he always
admired how his own parents would work
as a team in order to make their
circumstances work he later joked that
he was looking for someone sort of like
MacGyver someone who was able to get him
out of a third-world prison he was lucky
to find her while he was still working
his job a de Shore McKenzie Tuttle was a
fellow Princeton alumini who is applying
to work for the firm since Jeff Bezos
was the one in charge of hiring new
candidates he saw her resume and even
before meeting her he knew that she was
clearly a very intelligent and capable
woman when she arrived for the job
interview
he felt Cupid's arrow strike him right
in the heart
even though office romances are
sometimes frowned upon they fell in love
now even though he secretly admired her
he didn't want to cross the line so it
was actually McKenzie who made the first
move and asked him out for lunch they
were dating for just three months before
they got engaged and they got married in
1993 when Jeff Bezos turned 30 years old
they had been married for only a year he
told his wife about his idea for an
online bookstore and that he wanted to
quit his job in order to pursue it they
decided to leave New York City in 1994
Bezos chose to start his company in
Seattle because it's also the location
of Microsoft so there was a lot of
talent in the tech industry living there
thin to find employees from it's also
thought cheaper to start a company there
compared to New York or Silicon Valley
they now have several children together
and they had built a rock-solid
foundation together long before
amazon.com never existed once the
company began to do well McKenzie was
able to fulfill her dream of becoming a
published author today Jeff Bezos he
puts family first he says that he
refuses to take any meetings before
10:00 a.m. because spending time with
his family and having breakfast with his
children before they go to school
there's more important to him than
anything else
[Music]
when Jeff and Mackenzie Bezos first
moved out to the west coast to start
amazon.com in 1994 at that time the
website only sold used books in his mind
Jeff Bezos imagined a bookstore with
millions of titles and he knew that that
would eventually be the end goal of the
company Mackenzie did the accounting and
he began building the website and
sourcing inventory in the beginning they
ran the company out of their garage
after receiving an order for a book Jeff
would go to thrift stores and used book
shops looking for the book that was
requested and then send it to the
customer through the mail if he could
not find it he would source it from
someone else online just to make sure
that the sale went through that way they
were able to run the company without
using much physical space when they were
ready to hire a team to help them run
the business out of their house the
staff of amazon.com it was only eight
people since the company did not have
much money he asked his employees to
make desks out of old doors even to this
day the door desk is still a tradition
at Amazon offices before bringing the
website live on to the world wide web
Bezos sent it to 300 of his friends so
that they could test it beforehand when
the team was getting ready to officially
launch the site in 1995 they had set up
the computer to ding every time that
there was a sale in the beginning
everyone would shout and share every
time there was a new sale but within
just a few days there were so many sales
that they grew tired of the noise and
there to turn it off the website was so
popular they were getting business
through word-of-mouth without paying a
single dime for press coverage Jeff's
idea it was absolutely working and it
was clear to the team that the company
would become a success the reason why
amazon.com succeeded so quickly was that
Bezos was filling a very real need that
people had it was the very first online
bookstore before even Barnes & Noble
began selling their stock on the
internet ever since then Amazon
continued to pioneer various aspects of
incorporating the Internet into people's
daily lives and he says that for seven
years there was no competition that was
similar to what he was doing in 1997
Bezos wanted to take amazon.com public
thankfully he still had connections on
Wall Street so he knew exactly how to
approach investors with a business plan
he fully admitted that he did not
actually intend to make any
profit for the first five years that the
company was operating Jeff Bezos gave
stock options to all of his original
employees and this made them very
motivated to make the company succeed
after a couple of years every single one
of those eight employees had become
multimillionaires after a while Bezos
wanted to sell far more than just books
he emailed a thousand random customers
asking what sorts of items they would
like to buy on the Internet
soon enough he was getting replies of
items in just about every category
he realized that he wanted to grow
Amazon into a store that sold everything
and he began using the same method that
he had with books listening a product
online buying the item in person and
then shipping it to the customer of
course this only helped the company grow
even more
but even after earning millions of
dollars Bezos continued to drive his
beat-up old Honda he wanted to show his
employees that he still stood by his
core values of frugality and
resourcefulness instead of spending that
money on himself he reinvested the money
to make amazon.com better they bought
out other competing online book
retailers and brought them into the fold
he also decided to give anyone in the
United States the opportunity to sell on
the Amazon platform as third-party
sellers which only made the platform
stronger because it expanded their
inventory every decision Jeff Bezos made
for the expanding business was with the
future in mind when he learned about
ebooks he gave the people the
opportunity to self publish their work
online for the first time and earn an
income next he develops the Kindle
e-reader to give people a place to read
all of their ebooks when he saw Digital
streaming services becoming popular he
jumped on that bandwagon as well and the
list of things like this it just goes on
and on
today amazon.com is one of the most
massive corporations in the world and
they have dipped their toes into so many
different industries at this point that
it's kind of hard to keep track
Amazon has been criticized for putting
independent bookstores out of business
even major corporations like Borders
books simply could not compete according
to Amazon coms former manager Mike
Daisey Amazon is designed from the
ground up to be a shock it's designed to
dissolve and destroy other businesses by
undercutting them however Jeff Bezos
argues that he should not be blamed for
the downfall of these other businesses
because the future was coming no matter
watch whether it was him or someone else
Jeff Bezos says that whenever he makes a
major business decision he imagines
himself at 80 years old and if he would
be proud of his actions looking back if
the answer is yes he listens to that
intuition and he goes for it by
listening to his heart he has become one
of the most successful people in the
world Amazon has been incredibly
successful and a lot of people
attributed to Jeff Bezos his skills in
leadership he has a list of core values
Fama's on and he always abides by those
rules himself at the end of the dot-com
bubble the value of Amazon's stock went
from a hundred and thirteen dollars per
share all the way down to six dollars
per share for many members of the
original team they lost millions of
dollars in their stock portfolio and
this was enough to destroy the vast
majority of those early internet
businesses one of the many reasons why
Amazon survived was that Jeff Bezos
wasn't judging the business's success on
the stock price he knew that people were
still using the website and that it was
growing every single day as we mentioned
before Bezos always made his customers
the number one priority whenever he
received a very serious complaint he
would never try to reprimand his
employees for making a mistake instead
he would forward a particularly
troubling customer complaint to the
manager of each department with a simple
question mark in the subject line
according to former employees getting
one of those question mark emails was
terrifying and they would quickly do
everything they could to fix the problem
immediately when the issues were
resolved Bezos would simply reply with a
smiley face if he sees a bad experience
that a customer has he uses it as a case
study to improve the company overall and
not just that one person's individual
experience Amazon is now available in 16
countries so he has had to give up much
of the power over those branches of the
company since he can't be everywhere at
once some countries are actually trying
to fend off Amazon's monopolies in
certain industries in France for example
there is a law that no bookstore whether
it be online or in person is allowed to
discount a book by more than five
percent off the retail price and they
cannot give free shipping to entice
buyers this way independent bookshops in
France still thriving only time is going
to tell how many nations are going to
adopt Amazon in the future by a stroke
of genius Jeff Bezos has managed to run
amazon.com with little to no profit
despite the fact that they are bringing
in billions of dollars in revenue every
single year this is because he's always
thinking about the future and trying to
grow the business to keep pushing the
envelope and what is going to happen
next
Bezos is still a true Trekkie at heart
so it's really no surprise that he is
creating a private space company he
called Blue Origin just like he said
during his high school graduation speech
he still believes that someday it will
be very normal for people to be living
and working in space and he wants to be
on the forefront of that future at the
time that we're making this video Jeff
Bezos is worth a hundred and thirty
seven point six billion dollars and that
makes him the wealthiest man in all of
history
amazon.com it's been valued at over a
trillion dollars and of course there is
always the chance that this wealth will
grow but he isn't just hoarding all of
this money to himself he created the
Bezos family foundation and asked the
world what charitable cause he could
help pay for he received 47,000 emails
with suggestions about where the money
should go and he spends a lot of time
reading some of the best ideas for
causes that truly matter
he said all of the best decisions are
made with instinct intuition and heart
Jeff Bezos says that he wants to give
his money away to many of these
charities and invest more in start-up
business ideas that will help humanity
he decided to begin this journey by
opening tuition-free Montessori
preschools in underprivileged
communities so that children can have
the same opportunities that he did he
also wants to open homeless shelters
that allow an entire family to stay
together instead of splitting men and
women apart as time goes on we'll see
just how much Jeff Bezos uses his money
for good and he's always open to
suggestions so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe
brand new videos every week also if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now click one of the videos
on the screen that's some of the stuff
from our archives and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]